good morning
i am assistant sheriff lozaro chavez and
i'm here to brief you on additional
details
as we know them today about the
officer-involved shooting
that occurred on november 17
2021 this is ois number 10 for 2021
fatal number six
same time last year we were at ois
number 17
and fatal number nine
this event was initiated as a robbery
that occurred at 11 25 a.m november 17
2021.
the officer-involved shooting occurred
in the 3300 block of north tanea
las vegas nevada 89129
which is in the northwest area command
you can see the scene to my left
the officers involved are sergeant
donald graham he's 59 years old and has
been with lvmpd since 1998.
in this incident sergeant graham was
armed with a glock 21 45 caliber handgun
the incident revealed
the investigation revealed that he fired
one round
during this incident
officer number two is amelia lucak
she's 40 years old and has been with
lvmpd since
2004. in this incident
officer lucack was armed with a glock 19
nine millimeter
handgun the investigation revealed she
fired 20 rounds
during the incident
both officers are assigned to the
community policing division
at northwest area command
the suspect
has been identified as stephen thomas
he is 36 years old
black male adult 6 to 185 pounds
he's also pictured to my left
in this incident thomas was armed with a
semi-automatic springfield xd e
9 millimeter handgun
the investigation revealed thomas did
not fire any rounds during the incident
thomas's charges
had he survived
include robbery with a deadly weapon
five counts
assault with a deadly weapon on a
protected person
and resisting a public officer with a
deadly weapon
[Applause]
the details of the officer-involved
shooting are as follows
before i go into all the details i will
provide some information on a series of
crimes that stephen thomas committed on
the day
before he was located and confronted by
police
so beginning with november 17 2021
at 11 25 a.m
lvmpd received a call from a citizen who
stated he had been robbed at gunpoint in
a parking lot at the 1700 block of north
decatur boulevard suspect thomas took
the victim's vehicle at gunpoint
a short while later at 11 27 a.m lvmpd
received another call from a convenience
store located at the 5400 block of vegas
drive
reporting an attempted robbery
the caller stated that thomas
entered the business with the firearm
and demanded money from the safe
the employee was
unable to open the safe and thomas left
the store
in the stolen vehicle he had taken in
the previous event
then again a short while later at 11 34
a.m
lvmpd received the call from a credit
union at the 7200 block
of west lake mead boulevard reporting
that the suspect thomas
entered the business with the firearm
and demanded money from the tellers
thomas took the money and fled the
the scene
at which time sergeant graham and
officer lucac
who were in the area of the credit union
observed the stolen vehicle traveling on
tanea
from cheyenne
thomas stopped and got out of the
vehicle
we're in a near an apartment complex at
the 3300 block of north tenea
sergeant graham observed thomas
reaching for his waistband
and struck him with his patrol vehicle
thomas got back up
pointed his firearm at sergeant graham's
direction
it's at this point that officer lucak
exited her vehicle and yelled for thomas
to drop the gun
thomas ignored the commands
and started to walk towards her
while still armed
officer lucak and sergeant graham fired
at thomas striking him
causing him to fall to the ground
thomas attempted to get up with his gun
several times and officer lucac fired
until he stopped moving
officers responded i'm sorry officers
approached thomas and rendered aid until
medical personnel arrived
thomas was transported to umc trauma
where he was pronounced deceased
during the course of the investigation
detectives learned that on the day of
the officer-involved shooting thomas
grabbed a gun
and told his girlfriend
he was going to do something to get the
police
to shoot him
i will now show you the body worn camera
videos from the officer involved
shooting
[Music]
show me your hands
[Music]
show me your hands
show me your hands
[Music]
here's some slow motion video
of thomas exiting the vehicle and he
reaches
for his waistband
3250 nortonea suspect vehicle
is going to be at a stop 32.50 north
tanea guys
body worn camera from officer luke
[Music]
hands out
stay out
stay out
down
get down
show me your hands
[Applause]
[Music]
god
despite being struck by the vehicle
you'll see thomas
stands back up
and he points his firearm at sergeant
graham's
direction
which is when officer lukak
engaged him in gunfire
there's a better view of it
okay
this concludes the briefing
are there any questions
was mr thomas a career criminal uh
before that day where he
uh did the four crimes all in one day
was he had he had previous history
he did have some previous history but
that will be provided to you after the
press conference
sir i just want to double check you said
that the investigation found that the
suspect did not fire his gun
that's correct he pointed it at the
people in the store he pointed it at
the people inside the bank
and then he pointed it at the police
officers
okay
thank you very much